大家好,很榮幸能夠為大家帶來本次綜合案例與實戰金融封控聯合建模的實驗掩飾視頻
本視頻主要以金融封控聯合建模為例,介紹如何使用Secret Note在線平台完成實驗
本視頻主要分為以下四個部分,首先介紹案例背景
本實驗案例的背景是,隨著農村經濟的蓬勃發展,金融服務的補給在推動其全面發展中扮演著至關重要的角色
小額信貸服務為農村商業和個人帶來了新的機遇,但農村用戶信用記錄薄弱
傳統封控手段在風險識別和預測方面存在明顯短半
風險控制和信用評估難度增大,制約了金融服務的廣泛應用和創新發展
本案例的目標是,如何在確保隱私保護的條件下對信貸風險進行準確預測,進而促進農村普惠金融發展
接下來介紹第二部分,數據級概數與資段分析
銀行提供的數據級文件Back.csv中包含ID信貸特徵和弱風險特徵
例如貸款金額貸款期限信用等級借款人職業和借款人一年的收入以及是否發生違約情況等
以共22個字段,數據中包含數值型特徵和類別型特徵
例如貸款金額為數值類型而信用等級為類別類型
為了方便後續建模的邏輯回歸模型能夠正常訓練
而邏輯回歸本質上只能接受數值型輸入,因此我們需要對數據進行處理
例如類別類型需要通過1號的編碼成為數值類型
過大或分佈極端的數值類型需要進行標準化
也就是規劃到相近範圍,保證模型的收斂效率
在表格中,我們標註了本實驗中需要進行標準化和1號編碼的數據
總體來說,本數據及包含有限數量的結構化數據
信貸相關的信號牆,但是風險相關的信號角落
支付平台提供的數據級為Behavior.csv文件
具有消費相關的特徵和豐富的用戶交互關係數據
與Back.csv可以通過ID字段進行關聯
這個字段代表貸款記錄的唯一標識符
另外,從N0到N14是15個匿名特徵
包含消費品次,支付習慣,社交互動等
這些數據由於分佈不一,需要與Back.csv的數據一起進行標準化
這個數據集中包含海量非解構化行為數據
風險表徵能力強,但是缺乏直接信貸的信息
接下來進入第三部分,數據處理與建模思路
本次實驗是通過音譽的多方安全計算技術
構建一個有效預測金融風險的模型
實現銀行和第三方支付平台之間的安全聯合建模
我們首先需要進行實驗配置
然後加載數據級,並以ID為建值對齊數據級
轉換為縱向聯邦學習格式
在特徵工程中,首先按照上述描述過程
先將分類字段編碼為數值,然後將過大的數據標準化
最後劃分數據級為特徵和目標標籤用於後續的訓練過程
整體的建模思路為,使用銅泰加密和邏輯回歸模型
進行安全聯合建模
在加密數據上訓練邏輯回歸模型,並進一步進行測試
接下來進入Secret Note中進行具體的實操
這裡我們看到的就是銀與實訊平台的界面
首先我們將原本提供的Notebook
先刪除掉重新上傳一版
銀與Secret Flow實訊平台為我們提供了該案例的代碼
我們可以通過點擊首頁的案例
其中第一項就是金融風險預測,也就是本案例
在案例詳情頁面中,我們可以看到
提供了Notebook和數據級的下載面積以及Notebook的預覽
在此處,我們可以通過點擊兩項下載
按鈕,把對應的Notebook和數據級下載到本地再上傳到平台
也可以選擇在本頁面中直接複製代碼到對應的頁面
我們這裡選擇下載到本地再上傳
這裡上傳成功,點擊之後可以進入這個頁面
然後我們重啟這個Notebook
並且把所有的輸出全部清空
這裡我們點擊節點列表的加號按鈕進行節點的添加
在本試驗中是包括agency和back兩個節點
添加每一個節點的過程大概是30秒
這裡agency已經添加完畢,接下來添加back
我們可以看到在左方已經出現了agency的文件管理系統和節點監控的一些信息
這裡全部創建完成
接下來我們向這兩個參與方節點中分別添加文件
agency具有的文件是behavior.csv
這裡已經上傳成功,然後在這裡我們可以
越南表格也可以重新把它下載下來
然後這裡back也上傳相應的back.csv文件
好,這裡已經上傳成功,然後接下來我們進行實驗
首先需要加載相應的pattern cool分別是secret flow和spo
這裡雙方都需要執行,我們可以通過點擊運行也可以通過快捷鍵
好,執行完成
接下來進行實驗配置
由於雙方需要從特定的節點執行不同的任務
因此我們需要先執行下輸的unused tcpport這個函數
查找未被佔用的端口號
並且需要記錄這裡的端口號
用於後續配置refad
這裡同樣選擇雙方節點執行
好,我們這裡可以得到兩個未被佔用的端口號
然後在這裡配置refad的時候
我們需要將對應的ip和端口號
全部修改為我們配置好的實際的ip和端口號
比如說這裡agency它的ip是172.16.0.251
我們將它複製
然後拷貝到這裡
對應的端口號也拷貝過了
這裡端口號也需要修改掉
然後back的ip是172.16.0.2
這裡不需要修改
我們再確認一下
沒問題
然後back的端口號需要進行修改
類似的
因為這裡我們通過self party指定了配置這個refad的實體
這裡是back
然後下方是agency
因此需要分別修改他們的ip和端口號
好,修改完成
另外需要注意的是secret note
每個參與方他們默認的瑞集群的地址都是127.0.0.1
這兩個部分的代碼是需要各自的節點單獨執行
但是這兩個代碼塊是需要同時執行的
因此我們這裡需要選擇執行節點
是對應self party這個字段
這裡選擇是back
這裡選擇是agency
我們通過執行這個init韓數
構建雙方的一個跨機構通訊
這對我們通過快捷鍵執行
我們可以看到雙方已經執行完畢
在輸出中
可以發現雙方會互相進行ping操作
我們可以看到由於有一點點時間差
back是在第二次嘗試ping的時候拼通了agency
agency是在首次
pingback的時候就成功了
接下來進行spo配置
用於進行安全多方計算
因為銀行和第三方支付平臺需要從新的端口
啟動參與計算
所以我們這裡還是需要再執行一次
iOS的TCB part這個韓數
獲取目前沒有使用的端口號
當然是雙方都需要執行
執行完畢
接下來我們將下方的
在配置這個spo的時候
把裡面的ip和端口號
全部修改為實際的ip和端口號
這裡back
端口號是39171
agency ip需要修改
端口號是34631
然後run time config
是相關的一些配置參數
比如說使用的多方計算協議
和使用的有限域等
我們執行之後
可以得到一個spo的實例
好 執行完畢
接下來加載特定的數據集
這裡我們已經將雙方的數據
已經分別上傳到服務器
但是由於這裡是在線平臺
我們需要獲取當前的工作環境
加載特定的文件
執行getcwd寒數
獲取兩個文件的路徑
並且讀取它們
這裡我們分別執行這三個代碼塊
我們這裡輸出
可以看到它在服務器中的路徑
是在secret note底下的
一個工作環境當中
這裡可以將兩個文件
分別加在進來
我們剛剛了解的這兩個文件
接下來以公用的id作為建置
讀取這兩個文件
通過spo指定計算使用的spo
得到一個新的垂直數據框架
也是一個dataframe
這個dataframe是後續用於
多方安全計算的
這裡分別執行
好 執行完畢
接下來我們可以通過執行
shape和columns
這兩個寒數分別查看
得到的垂直數據框架的一些信息
shape會輸出
這個數據框架的行數和列數
columns會輸出列名
這裡我們可以看到
這些信息就是包含在
這兩個csv當中的信息
但是去除了id
因為在上方執行的時候
丟棄了id這一列
接下來我們對數據進行特徵工程
你在數據加密的時候
進行訓練
實現銀行和第三方支付平臺的
安全聯合建模
首先進行
這裡是將非數值類型的數據
轉換為數值類型
比如說類別這樣的信息
便於模型進行處理
我們這裡可以看到
包括term purpose這些信息
這裡也需要選擇雙方節點進行執行
在這個代碼塊當中
是將這些編碼後的數據
重新寫入到了這個數據框架中
並且把原有的這些信息
全部丟棄掉
我們執行這些代碼
好 執行完畢
接下來
我們進行數值的標準化
也就是消除這些代款
金額數據之間的差異
並且可以加快
模型訓練的收點速度
我們這裡也是分別選擇
雙方節點進行執行
我們執行這部分的代碼
好 執行完畢
這裡我們可以查看
經過編碼和標準化之後的列明
我們可以看到
執行完後的引口點之後
這些列數是進行了增加
也就是這些信息
他們根據數據類別進行了一個分割
然後接下來
我們將數據級分割為特種和標籤
用於後續的訓練
這裡標籤是EaseDefault這個字段
它代表的含義是
這條代款記錄是否違約
剛好符合我們
進行金融風險預測的需求
這裡也是選擇雙方節點進行執行
好 我們這裡進行了數據的分割
接下來我們進行
同態加密和加密邏輯回歸
模型訓練
我們首先進行配置
初始化參與運算的銀行
和第三方平台實體
然後使用提供的數據進行訓練
這裡也是選擇雙方節點
好 我們分別執行
好
那麼接下來
我們使用提供的數據進行訓練
一共需要進行四個迭代週期
那麼這個訓練過程
大概需要15分鐘能夠完成
好 我們可以看到
這裡已經執行完成的訓練
一共進行了四個輪次
接下來我們使用
model.predict這個函數
進行模型的預測
並且可以通過review
這個函數得到解密的值
那麼這個plane是實際的值
然後predict是預測的值
然後通過計算
rcac分數可以得到模型的效果
這個數值越大的話
證明模型的效果越好
我們這裡先選擇執行節點
然後分別執行
我們可以看到
這裡模型的效果
多出來的結果
大概是0.62
說明模型的效果是可以的
最後一個部分
進行本實驗的總結
在本實驗中
銀行和第三方支付平台
通過營運的多方安全計算技術
在確保數據隱私的情況下
利用雙方數據
構建一個有效的金融風險模型
可以有效提高金融服務
在農村經濟中的應用和創新發展
同時也驗證了
銀與技術在敏感數據
協作中的使用價值
本次分享到此結束
希望大家批評指證